but again everybody you're very welcome
to join us on the breakfast show here on
Sky News joining us on the program now
is the shadow leveling up secretary
Elisa nandi hello to miss nandi I
believe you've had a bit of problem with
the traffic this morning hopefully
everything okay now I want to talk to
you first of all about what's going on
with Dominic Raab your thoughts
um I think this is yet another sign that
you've got a prime minister who is not
in control of his own party we've got
this extraordinary situation where the
Prime Minister can't even say whether he
was aware of allegations surrounding
Dominic Robb I have to say as somebody
who said on your show previously Kay
that when I shadowed Dominic Robb I
heard a number of rumors about
allegations of bullying within the
department it seems to me extraordinary
that the Prime Minister wouldn't have
heard about that and yet appointed
Dominic Robb to the second highest
position in British politics it just
shows that this is a prime minister who
doesn't act until he's forced to he's
drugged to do it Kicking and Screaming
he's far too weak to control his own
party and once again the country is
playing the price for this ongoing Tory
Psycho Drama
uh Kurt but not a Bolly says uh one very
senior civil servant about Mr Rob
um suggests it's a group of mandarins
trying to oust him
I mean I think that the sheer volume of
people who seem to have come forward
during this inquiry would suggest
otherwise the Prime Minister will of
course say he's waiting for the outcome
of that inquiry but what it looks like
to me as a prime minister who is
frightened of taking action in case
there are further repercussions in his
own party he's far too weak to stand up
to people in his own cabinet if he's too
weak to stand up to people in his own
cabinet what hope is there that he's
going to go out and fight for the
interests of the British people
um okay we were speaking to one of your
colleagues yesterday we've been speaking
to a leader of the Civil Service union
today they were saying if he stays in
post while this continues potentially
those in his Department
um are not safe I mean that's taking it
too far isn't it
but we don't know that's part of the
problem the Prime Minister won't
disclose what he knew before reappointed
Dominic Rob he's got this lengthy
investigation going on to deal with all
of the allegations surrounding the
Deputy Prime Minister in several
different government departments that he
served in and in the meantime we've got
serious problems in this country
including in Dominic Robb's own
constituency we've uncovered figures
recently showing that the number of
people released on probation who go on
to commit serious crimes is
extraordinarily high at the moment
you've got problems on the railways
you've got problems on the roads as I
found out this morning you've got
problems in our schools and in our
hospitals and this is a government that
just cannot focus on the job at hand
because they're far too absorbed in
their own internal squabbling this has
been going on for far too long we don't
need another change of prime minister we
need a change of government
um I want to ask you as the shadow
leveling up secretary about the story
that's on the front page of the times
today about people representing British
gas literally breaking into the homes of
vulnerable to put in these uh prepayment
meters there's a video on their website
this morning where this guy says that it
basically gets a kick out of doing it
what on Earth's going on there it's
horrific what the times has done with
this investigation is lift a lid not
just on a series of immoral practices
but a rotten culture behind it where
people were being encouraged to go into
the homes of elderly people of people
with disabilities and families with
children Force these prepayment meters
and get bonuses for doing so I think
it's right that British gas has
suspended this practice I think this
practice should be suspended across the
board but we need wider action to deal
with the scandal of prepayment meters it
cannot be right that people on
prepayment meters some of the poorest
people in our country pay more for their
energy costs than people on Direct
debits we believe that that price has to
come down and we want this a moratorium
on these practices of fitting prepayment
meters forcibly in people's homes until
we've sorted out the wider problems and
make sure that poorer people pay a fair
price for their energy
interest rates likely to go up again
today as a result we'll see mortgage
rates go up to what's your advice for
people who are struggling
well I I the first advice is to put
pressure on the government put pressure
on your local conservative MP if you
have one to try and expand the windfall
tax if we close the loopholes in the
windfall tax shell today announcing
record profits again we could get help
to people now because it's not just that
interest rates are going up and then
potentially people's mortgages again
it's that the energy price cap is going
to be increased in April and people will
find themselves paying far more in
energy costs at a time when they can
barely afford it already we need a
government that will make fairer choices
in this country when you've got
organizations institutions that are
making record profits we ought to be
sharing the distribution of those
profits far more widely in order to get
helps people now that's what we would do
in government and that's what we're
urging the government to do
um okay um it's obviously a challenge
for plenty of people we not these those
who are going on strike at the moment we
saw half a million workers on strike um
earlier on this week spoke to the former
head of the NHS earlier today he says
that nurses should be a special case do
you think they should
well I think nurses are incredibly
special and Incredibly valued by most
people in this country but I think it's
undeniable that there are problems
across the board there are people in
many many lines of work including
teachers that we've seen this week
paramedics as well who are really really
struggling with the cost of living
they've done everything that they can to
hang on to our children to hang on to
our patients to keep us going they've
been a Lifeline over the last few years
but increasingly they're voting with
their feet we've got shortages across
social care we've got shortages in our
schools we're not recruiting enough
teachers we're not retaining enough
teachers and we're seeing the same in
the National Health Service as well in
the interests of people in this country
the government has got to get a grip on
this across the board it cannot be in
the interests of children to have record
numbers of teacher shortages
uh let's talk about Boris Johnson who
says you are out of your mind if you
think he covered up lockdown parties are
you out your mind
is anyone listening to Boris Johnson
anymore I don't care what Boris Johnson
is saying in his latest desperate bid to
grab headlines I think people in this
country and conservative MPS made up
their minds quite a long time ago about
Boris Johnson he made the rules he broke
the rules he lied about it and he
laughed about it he was completely unfit
to hold office and the fact that he was
able to attain the highest office in the
land is a real scar on the conscience of
the Tory party those Tory MPS knew him
they knew him well they knew his record
and yet they still put him in office and
continued to defend him for a long time
even as that damage was done to the
country
um yes I just want to go back to the
bullying thing didn't want to just focus
on that at the top all the way through
but
um we've seen your boss criticizing
Rishi sunak for not suspending um
Dominic Robb but we heard um Mr sunac at
pmqs yesterday saying that a member of
your own party Rosie Duffield said that
being in the labor party is like being
in an abusive relationship so that you
know potentially double standards there
well we take women's Safety and Security
very seriously there was an incident in
Parliament recently where Rosie Duffield
was heckled by Tori and labor MPS but
but labor MPS we take very seriously
because they're in our own party that's
not acceptable it's not acceptable to
have people being shouted down in
Parliament and I'm very happy to say so
and to make that clear both in public on
your showcase but also in private as
well to my colleagues which I have done
in the past and I will continue to do
but I don't accept that labor doesn't
treat women properly that we don't take
women so it's women's issues seriously
with a party that's pioneered reforms
from when we were in government through
work the work of people like tassajal
with surestart which was a Lifeline for
a lot of young mums in this country all
the way through to the fact that we you
know Harriet Harman and the work that
she's done over many decades to get
better representation in Parliament has
meant that people like me has sitting
here talking to you today we'll never
give up on the fight for women's
equality but I don't accept that labor
is not a party that stands up for women
I think our record shows otherwise okay
always good to talk to you thanks for
battling that traffic for us thank you